This episode was proudly made possible by
the all-new 2015 Subaru Legacy.
It's not just a sedan, it's a Subaru.
I am El Nino, all other tropical storms must
bow before me!!
We all remember that right?
But other than Chris Farley, what is an el
nino?
What's up DNewsers, it's Trace and this is
DNews.
Thanks for tuning in.
If you can remember 1997 and 98, you probably
remember the media storm surrounding that
year's El Nino.
People talked about it all the time, it was
HUGE weather news, mainly because it was the
strongest El Nino in decades and there were
a bunch in a row, which is rare.
You might’ve heard that 2014 is also an
El Nino year, though forecasters predict it’ll
be much weaker than the one in 97-98.
The name El Nino traces back to the 1600s,
when fisherman off the coast of Peru who noticed
warmer water usually appeared around Christmas-time.
They named it El Nino which means Little Boy,
or Christ Child in Spanish.
How that water GOT there, however, is crazy.
In a normal year, the trade winds blow from
east to west blowing the warm surface water
with it.
These winds create a kind-of hill of warm
water on Asian coasts.
That leaves the deeper, colder water to backfill
on the west coast of the Americas.
Basically, the temperatures of the ocean and
the atmosphere around the east-central equatorial
Pacific have a HUGE impact on weather patterns
around the world.
But sometimes these temperatures fluctuate,
in a cycle known as the El Nino Southern Oscillation,
or ENSO.
In an El Nino year, for some reason, the trade
winds are super weak, so they're not pulling
warm water to Asia.
Because of the warmer Americas, the trade
winds weaken even MORE causing the ocean to
warm even MORE!
That oscillation continues causing wetter
winters over the southeastern United States,
and dryer weather in Indonesia and Australia;
is also increases hurricanes in the eastern
Pacific while lessening those in the Caribbean.
La Ninas, are the opposite of El Nino, the
trade winds get really strong so we get COLDER
waters around the equatorial Pacific.
Which means warmer winters in the Southeast
US with fewer hurricanes in the Pacific and
more in the Caribbean, plus wetter summers
in Australia with more cyclones.
Guys, this shiz is a lot.
It's a house of cards.
When one thing changes, the whole system goes
nutso.
These ENSO events cause lots of problems with
flooding, cyclones, food production, snowfall,
and so on.
I mean, the water raining down on the Americas
has to come from somewhere.
Thus, Australia will likely see a terrible
drought this year, and India will probably
have a lessened monsoon season; meaning less
food production for both countries.
Not good, and these ENSO systems can go on
for more than a year!
The link between global warming and increased
ENSO events is still being checked out, but
a study in Nature Climate Change says that
global climate change is going to cause MORE
of these events, and they'll be stronger.
I've seen questions on why we haven't invented
weather controlling technology yet… this
is why!
We JUST started to understand how this all
works 30 years ago.
The events happen as part of the natural interaction
of water and wind in the Pacific ocean, and
thus can be monitored and predicted so governments
can prepare.
NOAA used to maintain 70 buoys strategically
placed across the oceans.
I say used to, because thanks to recent budgetary
limitations they can't afford to maintain
them anymore.
Therefore, NOAA's network of oceanographic
weather information is breaking down.
So… there's that.
It might not be long until El Nino catches
us by surprise, and that would be bad.
And before you ask, no we can't just invent
something to control the weather.
To do that, we'd need to control ocean temperatures.
Due to the amount of water IN the ocean, we'd
need to harness ALL the energy created in
the exploding of 400,000 20-megaton Hydrogen
bombs.
IF we could do that, we could heat the Pacific
by choice.
Seriously, don't get your hopes up.
So, what is an El Nino?
It's a cycle of warming and cooling that affects
the weather of the whole planet.
It's nature, bro.
Just nature.
And when it comes to the extremes of nature,
we wanna thank Subaru for making this episode
possible.
And especially the all-new 2015 Subaru Legacy.
Every sedan has its benefits, but only one
combines them all.
It’s not just a sedan.
It’s a Subaru.
Anything else you want to know about?
Any science questions you've really wanted
to get answered?
Leave them in the comments here below the
video and be sure you subscribe for all the
DNews every day of the week!
You can also follow me, Trace Dominguez and
the show DNews on Twitter and I'll answer
your science questions too!
Thanks for watching!